errors were made in the
hours following King Viserys' death
the war will be fought
many will die and the victor
will eventually ascend the throne
there's a war between kin
There is no war so hateful to the gods
and no war so bloody as a war between dragons
Welcome back everyone Happy New Year House of the
Dragon season 2 is coming finally they released
another trailer we learned some more about the
season and their plan for the rest of the series
George RR Martin also posted a bunch of updates
for all the other spin-offs and prequel series
because it is the end of the year as me posting
this video so we did a big Roundup we also learned
about a couple other new alternate endings to the
original Game of Thrones series confirming some
fan theories everybody's had for a long time so of
course we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos I'll be doing more season 2 videos
as we get more details and More Trailers for the
series it will be airing in 2024 thankfully they
also announced their casting for the night of the
Seven Kingdoms prequel series about the tales of
Duncan egg so it sounds like we might actually
get that Series in those episodes relatively soon
but that'll be a completely separate thing not
really connected to what's happening on House of
the Dragon that's like a completely separate show
it sounds like they're planning for that show to
fill the gaps between House of the Dragon Seasons
so that in the future we don't have long stretches
of time like years and years between House of
the dragon or Game of Thrones seasons however you
want to think about it we also got a little more
Cregan Stark he is going to debut during season
2 but he's not in this trailer they're probably
saving him for one of like the final trailers
because he is a huge character they confirmed
that he is being played by Tom Taylor who also
himself posted a few videos thinking everyone and
being hyped for his debut during season 2 before
I go to sleep I just thought I'd say thank you to
um everyone who's messaged and commented and and
just been really welcoming about my involvement
in House of the Dragon I'm really looking forward
to it yeah I'm knackered but thanks one of
the funny things about his Clips is some of
you probably realized he is a natural blonde
like wait a minute wouldn't that make him seem
like a Targaryen is this meant to be like a weird
Jon Snow reference or something more likely when
they filmed his scenes they either dyed his hair
brunette like Stark brunette or they just had him
wear a wig I do not think he's going to be blonde
during the actual season that would just confuse
so many people like what are they trying to tell
us here like is there some secret plot in play is
he secretly a Targaryen like Jon Snow based on all
the books Cregan Stark is Stark brunette but just
starting with the alternate endings some of these
are actually pretty cool the first big one is
actually the night King coming to King's Landing
with his army of white walkers and whites in what
looks like would have happened around episode
4 episode 5 maybe just based on the timing of
how everything goes down this is assuming that
season 8 was only ever going to be six episodes
total I believe a fan actually put that footage
together because some of it is taken from the
actual episode 5 and episode 6 events I definitely
think it would have made for a much better climax
to the long night story arc and done a better job
of setting up daenerys's turn as she slowly goes
mad and then eventually turns on King's Landing
herself but the other alternate ending actually
confirms a long running fan Theory and it comes
from Le heiti Cersei herself and this is specific
for cersei's ending recently she revealed
that when they were actually filming season
8 a couple years ago she and Maisy Williams had
a version of cersei's ending that was basically
a fan theory that most of had for cersei's ending
for a long time like even leading up to season 8
there were a lot of theories about how they'd end
her storyline turns out they were thinking what
we were all talking about she said their version
of cersei's ending during the finale instead of
being killed by the collapsing red keep itself
like crushed by Stones during the finale Arya
was going to have killed jime like we wouldn't
actually see that happen she would just take his
face wearing his face then sneak into the red keep
and in A Moment Like This Arya kills Cersei while
still wearing Jaime's face so that we the audience
as we're watching the episode see Jamie killing
Cersei there's like a big WTF reaction like oh my
God he killed her what happened and then Arya rips
her face off revealing that it's her to Cersei
as she lay Bleeding Out sort of like the way that
she entered season 7 with that fry P scene first
the WTF moment happens then she rips the face off
revealing that it's her so it would have been
A Moment Like That season 7 episode one moment
like the Starks send their regards I already did
a couple videos about the other deleted scenes
and alternate endings from Game of Throne season
8 so I'll add links for those videos at the end
of this and down the description below because it
was such a big season there were so many things
that hit The Cutting Room floor but moving to the
house of the Dragon season 2 trailer there are a
couple moments we learn more about in the trailer
you see Rhaenyra Mount Syrax angrily after the scene
looking out over shipbreaker Bay after hearing the
news of Lucerys' death rip this moment is meant to
be picking up right after this scene here of her
learning of her son's death it looks like in the
trailer she's actually going to mount Syrax
and fly to shipbreaker Bay around Storm's end
actually looking for Lucerys' body herself which
isn't a moment from the original Fire and Blood
book there are like a lot of moments they include
on the show that weren't in the original book for
a lot of different reasons in the books they made
it sound like the reason why she learned of her
son's de like the reason why the news reached
her at all is because his body already washed
up on shore so they'd already found his body
but this also gets into like the rest of the
show too because there will be other moments
that were not in the original book you have
to remember that the original Fire and Blood book
isn't written from the POV perspective like the
original A Song of Ice and Fire novels but in fire
and blood it's actually a book that's written by
maesters after the fact and taken from accounts
from mushroom the court fool George RR Martin and
the showrunners have talked about this so the
whole idea is that the maester that actually
wrote the book is very green leaning so already he
kind of didn't like Rhaenyra and the blacks there were
a lot of moments from history that they got wrong
or they weren't privy to like there weren't actual
people there seeing what actually happened what
the characters said to each other so be kind of
like somebody writing a biography about somebody
else without actually having been there or talked
to the person to get a first-person account of
what actually happened that's meant to explain
some of the discrepancies so the show is meant to
fill in a lot of those gaps like no no no this is
what really happened they've also addressed this
on the show too part of the idea is that the
Victor always writes history and it's always their
account of History so those accounts of History
always tend to favor the victors and not be
totally accurate to what history actually was we
got a couple new scenes of Corlys Velaryon inside the
map table room it's almost empty there's probably
another person that he's speaking with here he's
still a very important character in season 2
and they kind of teased his role at the end of
season one in the finale some of his character
turns most of his season 2 is using his Fleet to
blockade Blackwater Bay the other key ports that
the greens might otherwise use along the Eastern
Seaboard basically controlling this whole Eastern
Seaboard for the blacks he's involved in a
really huge WTF battle called the battle of
the gullet it sounds like they've actually put
push that to season 3 there have been a bunch
of questions about that they changed season 2
it's only eight episodes now instead of 10 and
I think it's because they decided to move the
battle of the gullet to season 3 mostly because
they want to do a much bigger version of it and
they just didn't have the budget for it or the
time to address it in a way they wanted to like
they would have had to do like 12 or 13 episodes
to do it right during season 2 I think they also
decided to move it so they could open season 3
with some Epic WTF action the way they're going
to do with season 2 episode 1 in Blood and cheese
very different kind of action very different
type of WTF moment but all the same just opening
it as strongly as possible in the battle of the
gullet is basically the bloodiest sea Battle in
the history of Westeros so you can imagine that
they want to spend way more time on it the other
big reminder too and they kind of got into this
during the finale is a sea snake implied in that
season 1 finale that neither he nor princess Rhaenys
really trusted Rhaenyra that much anymore and seemed
like he kind of soured on her just in general
but currently the best option for their family
like their part of the family the Velyarons was
to support her over the greens they're going to
continue to be moments like that in season 2 that
will cause corus to question his loyalty to rira
that will just inform what happens with him in
season 3 and just season 3 in general for all
the characters in a very Game of Thrones fashion
over the course of all these Seasons like over the
course of the dance of the Dragons alliances shift
and change constantly it would not be the Game of
Thrones Universe if people weren't backstabbing
each other or switching sides all the time also
too Corlys Velaryon is getting his own spin-off
although it might be played by a completely
different character George RR Martin was gushing
about blue-eyed Samurai like some other cool
animated projects right now saying that the sea
snake n voyages series that they were working on
is now moving to become an adult animation series
I don't know if this means it's going to be 2D
looking animation kind of like Invincible because
it's an amazing series or it'll be 3D animation
more like blue-eyed samurai either way I am really
excited about the idea of an adult animation Game
of Thrones series and George RR Martin said one
of the reasons why they moved it to animation is
just for budgetary reasons because they want to go
to so many places around the world and it's just
hard to do that in liveaction I've already talked
about all the blood and cheese scenes during the
trailer don't want to get too deep into that cuz
it is kind of spoilery remember that'll be like
the first couple of episodes of season 2 I've
already talked about Criston Cole wearing the
chain of the hand of the king and how he becomes
hand of the king basically taking Otto Hightower's
job that inform everything that happens later
in the season with the Battle of duskendale and
Rooks rest Rooks rest will be like the really big
battle in the middle of the season but it is in
the middle of the Season we'll get a couple more
trailers before season 2 actually gets here I'm
not expecting them to drop like a big Super Bowl
trailer or anything like that but there should be
some more promos pretty soon whatever they wind
up releasing and whatever we wind up hearing
about the other spin-off shows of course I'll do
videos there's a bunch of big stuff coming up so
if you have any big questions about what's going
on with the trailers or the new series just write
there in the comments below and I'll add them
to my bonus videos while you wait for everything
click here for my full House of the Dragon season
2 trailer video in Easter Eggs and click here for
that Game of Thrones Knight of the Seven Kingdoms
teaser trailer and learn what's going on with that
show thank you so much for watching happy New
Year everyone and I'll see you guys in the next one!